Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to take a bad choppy video,
and make a beautiful, smooth and creamy footage
out of it.
With today's camera and graphics technology,
we can create videos with 60 frames per second.
Those are really smooth, I also make each
of these videos using 60 frames per second,
however, it almost always happens that I encounter
the paper videos that have only from 24 to
30 frames per second.
In this case, I put them in my video editor
that has a 60 fps timeline, where half or
even more of these frames will not provide
any new information.
That’s neither smooth nor creamy.
And it gets worse.
Look!
As we try to slow down the videos for some
nice slow-motion action, this ratio becomes
even worse, creating an extremely choppy output
video because we have huge gaps between these
frames.
So, does this mean that there is nothing we
can do and have to put up with this choppy
footage?
No, not at all!
Look at this technique from 2019 that we covered
in an earlier video.
The results truly speak for themselves.
In goes a choppy video, and out comes a smooth,
and creamy result.
So good!
But wait, it is not 2019, it is 2021, and
we always say that two more papers down the
line, and it will be improved significantly.
From this example, it seems that we are done
here, we don’t need any new papers.
Is that so?
Well, let’s see what we have only one more
paper down the line!
Now, look.
It promises that it can deal with 10 to 1,
or even 20 to 1 ratios, which means that for
every single image in the video, it creates
10 or 20 new ones, and supposedly we shouldn’t
notice that.
Well, those are big words, so I will believe
it when I see it.
Let’s have a look together!
Holy mother of papers!
This can really pull this off, and it seems
nearly perfect.
Wow.
It also knocked it out of the park with this
one.
And all this improvement in just one more
paper down the line.
The pace of progress in machine learning research
is absolutely amazing.
But, we are experienced Fellow Scholars over
here, so we will immediately ask, is this
really better than the previous 2019 paper?
Let’s compare them!
Can we have side by side comparisons?
Of course we can!
You know how much I love fluid simulations.
Well, these are not simulations, but a real
piece of fluid, and in this one, there is
no contest.
The new one understands the flow so much better,
while the previous method sometimes even seems
to propagate the waves backwards in time.
A big checkmark for the new one.
In this case, the previous method assumes
linear motion when it shouldn’t, thereby
introducing a ton of artifacts.
The new one isn’t perfect either, but it
performs significantly better.
Do not worry for a second, we will talk about
linear motion some more in a moment.
So how does all this wizardry happen?
One of the key contributions of the paper
is that it can find out when to use the easy
way and the hard way.
What are those?
The easy way is using already existing information
in the video and computing inbetween states
for a movement.
That is all well and good if we have simple,
linear motion in our video.
But, look, the easy way fails here.
Why is that?
It fails because we have a difficult situation
where reflections off of this object rapidly
change, and it reflects something.
We have to know what that something is.
So, look, this is not even close to the true
image, which means that here, we can’t just
reuse the information in the video, this requires
introducing new information.
Yes, that is the hard way!
And this excels when new information has to
be synthesized.
Let’s see how well it does!
My goodness, look at that, it matches the
true reference image almost perfectly.
And also, look, the face of the human did
not require synthesizing a great deal of new
information, it did not change over time,
so we can easily refer to the previous frame
for it, hence, the easy way did better here.
Did you notice?
That is fantastic, because the two are complementary.
Both techniques work well, but they work well
elsewhere.
They need each other!
So, yes, you guessed right, to tie it all
together, there is also an attention-based
averaging step that helps us decide when to
use the easy, and the hard ways.
Now, this is a good paper, so it tells us
how these individual techniques contribute
to the final image.
Using only the easy way can give us about
26 decibels, that would not beat the previous
methods in this area.
However, look!
By adding the hard way, we get a premium quality
result that is already super competitive,
and, if we add the step that helps us decide
when to use the easy and hard ways, we get
an extra decibel.
I will happily take it, thank you very much!
And, if we put it all together, oh yes, we
get a technique that really outpaces the competition.
Excellent.
So, in the near future, perhaps we will be
able to record a choppy video of a family
festivity, and have a chance at making this
choppy video enjoyable, or maybe even create
slow-motion videos with a regular camera.
No slow-motion camera is required.
What a time to
be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!